this week's videos are sponsored by
manscape more on them after the reaction
people what is going on there citizens
of the reject Nation Greg and John here
today to watch the furiosa a mad mask
Saga trailer number one John how are you
witness my excitement g i uh haven't
seen the movie in a long time I'm
assuming that's a reference I saw it
once under some
extreme stuff sure yeah I I could use a
rewatch this to say ladies and gentlemen
right now uh John and I with the help of
a couple of other people my brother
Brandon mgar building a second space for
us to film at right now other people are
filming at the main space so we are just
using this because we need to at this
moment leave a like on this video that'd
be very much appreciated guys let's see
what the hype is all about because we
have been waiting for another Mad Max
film for a very very long
time
whatever you have to do Chrome to it's
cool it's getting however long it takes
it's getting more and more
orange promise me you'll find your way
home the true origin
story give me this promise oh hell yeah
with
hair the origins of how she became bald
yes there's got to be like a weep
shave
Montage a young furiosa is taken from
her family she will devote the rest of
her life to finding her way home this is
hery and if you want to know how she
found her way home watch the last movie
yeah the start of how she tried to get
home and spent a very long time doing
[Music]
so was that Chris Hemsworth that lady
and
oh my
[Music]
God didn't recognize that there's so
many app
Prosthetics
[Music]
everyone oh it's beginning
mhm and it's going to get to use accent
survive while the bullets are flying in
there
wow whoa
oh love story too oh her arm with the
sleeve exposing
it there we go ramp that engine up
woo God
[Music]
B the darkest of
angels oh nipple
[Music]
chills
damn it's like Army of Darkness the
question is
do you have it in you to make it
epic it's like Thor with a different
voice that's a pretty freaking awesome
trailer man yeah
remember and witness me wow what a true
expansion on the Saga right here damn
that was great I just ran a mile
seriously it's crazy seeing Chris
Hemsworth back with all that hair and
then fake teeth and like a fake nose and
then furiosa too with the shape John I'm
trying to transition to our sponsor
Jesus Christ L The Improv Mary balls
reject Nation you know what the funny
thing is I already owned this product
before agreeing to do this partnership I
could have used my influencer ring to
get it for free or at a discount but hey
now you can get it at a discount cuz
this week we are of course sponsored by
manscaped as a married man who's always
on the move I value looking sharp all
keeping things efficient and that's
where manscapes performance package 5.0
Ultra comes in featuring the lawn mower
5.0 and it is a game changer the package
is honestly a perfect gift for yourself
or for another man that you might know
I'll give this to John if anyone ask I
pay for it out of my own pocket but no
seriously this is easily the best
because it comes with not one but two
NextGen blade heads see the difference
it's good thing I have two now for
demonstration purposes so you got the
standard trimmer for a perfect neat trim
but this one the new foil blade for that
super smooth finish and oh yeah it's all
about safe grouping with their Advanced
Skin safe technology plus they're
waterproof so no more crumbs on the
carpet the package also encloses a weed
whacker 2.0 for ear and nose and I
definitely use this because look at me
I'm a hairy guy and the musthave liquid
formations the crop Soother aftershave
lotion and the crop preserver ball
deodorant say goodbye to postet of
irritation and hello freshness and the
ultimate cherry on top two free gifts
manscapes premium boxers 2.0 and the
2.0 toiletry bag again I already
have one the boxers I'm wearing up here
right now and the bag is perfect for all
your grooming Essentials as you can see
so you ready to elevate your grooming
game head to manscape.com and use code
rejects for a cool 20% off plus free
shipping remember it's rejects for 20%
off at manscape.com let's get those
jingle balls holiday ready with
manscaped this is like a true return to
the Mad Max form of what it has become
since Fury Road with its insane
eccentric kinetic visuals on full blast
here here uh the trailer surprisingly
breathed better in the beginning Parts
than I expected it to it feels like that
unlike the last movie which which I
recall being more of just this non-stop
essentially very long chase that
there'll be those elements of course you
got to have apocalyptic Road chases in a
Mad Max film that it'll probably be a
little bit more character driven
narrative as you would probably hope for
and expect considering this is the
origin tale of furiosa um it's it's it's
interesting because I I was most curious
to see like Anya Taylor Jord because
Charlie ston was uh you know the scene
stealer in the last movie and so it
makes sense why she would get uh her
character at least would get the
spin-off a lot of people were
disappointed by the fact that they
didn't bring back Charlie ston and they
got Ona Taylor joy in here I feel like
the talk of the trailer is probably
going to be Chris Hemsworth though you
know um but he's often doing that at
female
lils that Chris Emsworth boy knows how
to take the attention man I mean he just
knows how to have fun um but so I do
want to talk about him but for Anya
Taylor Joy U my first impression at
least of her is I mean she does seem to
demonstrate that prowess you do seem
like you're going to get a good
inclination of that growth and in terms
of An Origin tale we didn't really get a
dive too deep from my recollection into
uh everything the relationship she lost
the relationship she left behind and it
seems like that's what we'll see is
really experience the things that are
Stripped Away away from her and that
sense of loss to understand why she's
fighting to go back home so badly uh
this long build that we get to in Fury
Road uh but Anya Taylor Joy I think is a
phenomenal actress and it's cool to see
her take on a role that's going to
require this much amount of um strength
in to put better word yeah what do you
think man durability no I'm super
excited and and yeah I mean I really
like Ona Taylor Joy I do feel like yeah
she gets cast in like tons of stuff now
so she's kind of bordering on that on
that edge of maybe being like you know
female Pedro Pas c a little bit or
female uh Chris Pratt's voice acting
career the moment um but no like I I
really like her in general and this is
an exciting prospect to me because this
is the kind of movie that an actor has
to really throw themsel wholeheartedly
into you're going to be in the elements
it's going to be wild and it's probably
going to be really uncomfortable and I I
I feel like this trailer maybe gave me a
bit much for my taste of the you know
expansion of her Arc I didn't need to
see her with the shaved head in the
trailer I didn't need to see the arm in
the trailer or anything like that I
liked having hints and realizing we'll
probably get there um but that said I
really liked how this but how how did
Wolverine get the leather jacket and but
that's the nice thing is I feel like
prequels are often Troublesome because
yeah it's like how do we make this tense
and immediate without undercutting it by
the fact that we know what's going to
happen and I think they're in a unique
position with a movie like this to
really complement Fury Road but Al you
know these movies are very experiential
and they're very much about just kind of
like being there and the the feeling and
the grit of everything and and as of
like a Fury Road living in in the
quieter in between moments like you know
the actual life of the characters
they're not like super dense in terms of
like plot elements or even like
character beats but you really feel like
you spent time with and and like did a
harrowing thing with these people and so
I feel like this could be a unique
prequel that really can shed a lot of
the baggage many prequels have to and I
loved the prospect of Chris Hemsworth as
this uh you know wild you know a Mad Max
villain is going to be a chance for an
actor to really you know take hold of a
role and make it their own he looks like
The Botch Thor yeah but with a complet
different voice to it and then and then
his own probably Australian accent
because that's the other thing too is is
that an Australian accent it might be
I'd have to go back in this or was it or
was it his Australian accent peeking
through Maybe cuz you got to cast an
Australian actor and I mean you know
this franchise has its roots in
Australia you know mels the Australian
originally and stuff so I feel
like sure everyone's favorite person to
be remembered at the moment but uh yeah
no I'm really excited for the both of
them and just for the world in general
uh you know you're always nervous about
whether or not they're going to catch
lightning in a bottle the second time
and if it's going to live up to Fury
Road but at the same time uh yeah just
liked you know the swath of what we saw
here and uh yeah I'm excited well you
know it it it doesn't it it's not really
a criticism it's just more of an
observation when Fury Road came back
after Beyond Thunderdome it's called
Beyond Thunderdome right or is it just
called Thunderdome I think it's Beyond
Thunderdome Mad Max Beyond Thunderdome
I'm not even sure I've watched that one
I've not seen Thunder I've for sure seen
Mad Max one and War Warrior I've not
seen yeah yeah regardless uh I mean I've
seen like clips of a Thunderdome um seen
a Turner baby I think I've seen it I
must have seen it when I was like a
little kid uh I watched I was like
obsessed special s Gibson movies when I
was a kid so I I imagine I've I feel
like I saw it Now's the Time to go back
any um but when when Fury Rogue came
back they they reinvented itself yeah uh
entirely like while you still had you
know some of the the the familiarity of
landscape and you know the just the the
aesthetic but they really redefined
everything imagery of what it looks like
and what it feels like and this rapid
Pace about it the frenzyness and it
seemed this doesn't look like a
reinvention as much of it as continuing
that style which still feels appropriate
and is exciting you know like at the
same time I'm not here I don't have that
same feeling that I have with Aquaman
and the Lost Kingdom trailer where I'm
like this looks like the exact same
thing sure yeah yeah I think that's part
of I think that's why having Hemsworth's
role is actually really refreshing yeah
cuz it gives you a chance to think okay
maybe they're going to add some other
new and unique and interesting elements
because yeah it's like you had such a
massive length of time between
Thunderdome and Fury Road so that feels
like a massive reinvention I think this
franchise is lucky that it behooves them
to kind of disappear for a long time and
come back with a new one and yeah while
this doesn't look like a reinvention it
does look like a movie that's going to
carry itself a bit differently maybe at
least have a bit more character
interaction action directly as part of
the focus point of the plot or or the a
little that Happy Feet George Miller in
there definitely and you've got you know
the contrast with like uh uh what is it
the the you know land of many mothers or
whatever it is and and you know these
nighttime scenes with the blue and so
you know it's always a Salient moment
for an ecological message as these films
carry so uh yeah yeah well it's got It's
it's got that
medieval futuristic flare that I love so
yeah guys I love the trailer I thought
it was excellent and I feel like the
trailer delivered exactly what you'd
hope that a return to the Mad Max world
would deliver just with a bit more
CGI that was probably one of the only
neg criticisms I had was like I felt the
CGI a little bit the first one has CGI
but but it's not as widely praised for
its practicality and this this CGI was a
little more apparent this time I'm
curious yeah I'm like did you just get a
bigger budget and now you can try this
stuff out that could be fun but on the
other hand I am like I don't want this
this to feel too CG cuz the point is
like to feel like you've spent an hour
or two in the dirt yeah yeah but then
again the last one was a nightmare for
everyone to put together was but maybe
they need that who knows and and like
Charley ston and Tom Hardy were pretty
open about not getting along yeah and
they had to recut the movie like a bunch
of different ways and times this was
that was a really strenuous experience
so I imagine they were might have been a
part of George Miller who was is a
senior was like you know what I got to
maybe make a tad easier on myself right
now but guys what did you think about
the trailer leave your thoughts down
below be sure to subscribe leave a like
and hey thank you to our sponsor
manscape if you end up getting some
that's great gift to get people and if
you end up getting some let them know
reject Nation send you by using that
promo code we'll see you guys soon
thanks for being
[Music]
here